de se rendre compte que qu'on va mourir
et d'être conscient de sa mort et de se
poser ces questions existentielles même
même tous les jours en fait c'est assez
exceptionnel parce que ça te permet de
de savoir à tout moment de ta vie que tu
es en vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me suis rendu compte que j'avais de
la chance dans la manière dont je vivais
avec avec cette maladie avec la
mucoviscidose et que j'avais envie de
juste partager ma vie mon expérience
pour les pour les gens qui sont plus
jeunes que moi les enfants malades plus
jeune que moi et les parents d'enfants
malades plus jeune que moi afin qu'ils
puissent juste voir quelqu'un de mon âge
qui va bien et qui vit normalement avec
cette maladie j'ai un traitement
quotidien à faire et j'ai de temps en
temps des hospitalisations parce que
j'attrape une bactérie qui est
potentiellement dangereuse pour la
maladie donc enfin assez enfin
concrètement ma vie et pas très
différent de faim je fais du sport je
cours aussi vite que ma soeur ou que ou
que ma meilleure amie enfin je je voyage
je fais tout ce que fait une personne
normale ou plus parfois
et ouais donc c'est vrai que pour moi
c'est ultra important de de montrer des
gens qui ont cette maladie qui vont bien
fins et c'est je comprends pas pourquoi
c'est pas plus c'est pas pu se montrer
[Musique]
nous y passons à les équivalents des
programmes neuf et dix medicine
oh
c'est fascinant comme magique comme ça
peut être terrifiant et souvent très
douloureux mais c'est ça ça tu attends
mène dans l'est dans les tunnels de thé
do they peur des blessures afin que tu
puisses les les voir et une fois que tu
les as vu ba tu les accepte et du coup
ça ces blocages enfin s'en vont
disparaissent selon je m'étais pas rendu
compte
consciemment mais c'est que depuis que
j'étais tout petit faucheux jeu je me
suis posé des questions existentielles
assez intense fin tu vois quand
quant à trois ans et que tu vas à
l'hôpital et que tu dois faire des
traitements quelque part dans ton dans
ton corps est dans ton esprit tu
comprends que qu'il ya quelque chose qui
est différent pour toi que pour les
autres gens donc déjà cette espèce de de
se sentir très différent que ce qui est
vrai pour les autres n'est pas vrai pour
toi
et puis et puis ce rapport à la mort où
tu tu sais très bien très vite quant à
cette maladie ou peut-être d'autres
maladies que que la mort c'est quelque
chose qui qui est proche de toi en fait
c'est pas c'est ouais c'est quelque
chose qui est proche de toi et et de se
rendre compte de sa très jeune est de se
rendre compte que toi tu as conscience
de ça alors que les autres ils n'ont pas
forcément conscience
en fait c'est assez c'est très étrange
et et et ça te donne un parfum sentiment
de solitude qui est assez assez
vertigineux et est comme moi j'ai
toujours vu voulu vivre normalement
avoir l'air normal j'ai toujours jamais
parlé de ma maladie j'étais toujours
très forte je voulais toujours faire
plus plus aller plus loin plus vite plus
fort que que les autres pour je pense
pour montrer que j'allais très bien et
ça marche ça m'a permis de faire plein
de trucs mais
mais en fait ouais pendant ce voyage
j'ai compris enfin j'ai compris que que
que dans mon enfance et d'entendre la
dans la manière dont je me sentais tous
les jours il y avait des moments c'était
très difficile ça me permet de vivre de
manière plus plus vrai en fait
aujourd'hui et maintenant je peux je
sais que je peux je peux en parler je
peux te dire que ça va pas je sais que
c'est pas parce que je dis que ça va pas
que ça veut dire que je suis je vais te
considérée comme malade doit être
considéré comme faible je suis en vie
quoi j'ai de la chance
et de se rappeler de ça mais tout les
toutes les minutes en fin mais c'est
génial tu vois ça te permet de faire
fondre de vraiment faire tout ce que tu
veux
[Musique]